The lobby is sort of like your entry to your home.
You get a sense of both the company and its brand and what they stand for...
...as well as making somebody feel welcome and received.
When we have visitors come in,...
...I want there to be a little bit of a wow factor...
...and I want them to see it's a very efficient, very smooth,...
...very welcoming experience for them.
We used to check in people with a paper book.
We used to have to handwrite their name and write their email address.
We lost a lot of opportunity to actually do much more with somebody coming to visit.
Right now, with Envoy, people walk in, they swipe,...
...they enter a couple of details and they're ready to go.
It just makes the process faster, more efficient...
...and that makes my life a lot easier.
As soon as someone checks in with Envoy,...
...and I get something on my phone right away no matter where I am.
There's no guessing if they're here yet.
I don't need to have them text me or have the office administrators track me down.
I can rely on my phone pushing a notification and I can greet my guest at the elevator.